il y a d'autres manières d'éduquer que
par la peur notamment la menace et parce
qu'on sait maintenant parler dernières
découvertes en neurosciences que le
cerveau des enfants et à la fois
immature et fragile ce qui fait que
moins on utilise de méthode entre
guillemets qui soit contraignantes et
stressante et mieux c'est il y a quelque
chose d'essentiel pour éduquer un enfant
c'est le lien affectif lorsqu'on punit
on s'éloigne au lieu de se rapprocher et
le principe c'est justement de pouvoir
nourrir ce lit affectif parce que c'est
comme ça que l'enfant collaborera mieux
et n'obéira pas ça c'est important en
fait élaborer exactement collaborer
c'est ça exactement moi je dis souvent
mon fils ouais
c'est comme un pote bah il est tout le
temps avec moi on rigole il veut pécho
les meufs que j'ai envie de pécho ta
voiture
je comprends ce qu'il veut dire après il
y en a qui sont pas d'accord avec vous
je sais que par exemple vous Béatrice
vous venez parce qu'en fait vous voyez
les choses de façon binaire où on les
bonsoir d'abord où on est punit tout le
temps ou on les punit jamais c'est pas
ça on a un lien avec son enfant on a un
lien affectif on discute mais quand il
franchissent certaines limites une ligne
rouge là il faut qu'il comprenne
fermement que ça c'est une limite à pas
franchir et moi j'ai deux enfants quatre
et 7 je peux vous dire que c'est
impossible de de on est obligé de les
punir à certains moments sinon ils
peuvent se mettre eux-mêmes en danger et
c'est grave et dans une société comme on
la voit avec toute cette permissivité où
on parle de retour à l'uniforme de
retour à la dictée on a besoin
d'autorité je trouve que c'est pardon
mais désastreux ce que vous êtes en
train de dire et si vous faites des
émules je pense que ça va être un
désastre au niveau de la société
Jean-Marie oui moi je pense que tu as
dit un mot essentiel c'est
la fermeté moi je pense qu'il faut de la
fermeté et de l'amour les deux choses
fermement avec amour évidemment c'est
dur à combiner mais c'est exactement ce
qu'il faut faire c'est à dire STOP ça tu
peux plus le faire d'abord une
différence entre corriger on dit
corriger c'est un coup de trick non
corrigé ses corrigé punir c'est punir
corriger ces corriger le tir tu dis tu
fais pas comme ça tu fais comme ça c'est
comme ça c'est mieux puis ça merde
personne mais il est nécessaire d'être
ferme avec amour
d'amitié mais avec fermeté vous êtes une
tortionnaire éducative
[Applaudissements]
et moi je relais défonce là et moi je
vous le dis avec énormément d'amour je
n'aimerais pas être votre enfant parce
que ce que vous avez dit punir
aujourd'hui ça veut dire quoi c'est le
bonnet d'âne c'est fils dans ta chambre
vous rendez compte de ce que vous dites
vous êtes la France du passé vous avez
parlé d'uniforme mais ça ne m'étonne pas
de vous vous êtes la France qui ne sait
pas éduqué et vous projetez sur vos
enfants
[Applaudissements]
ont jeté sur vos enfants vos propres
névroses papa positive va vous le dire
et ça c'est pas bien
changé de méthode et non là mais non
vous êtes le scandale de la France vous
êtes la France du passé
non j'y vais pas doucement ça m'énerve
je préfère un parent qui excédait dit à
son enfant fils dans ta chambre qu'un
parents excédé qui n'arrive pas à se
contenir et qui lui en colle une donc je
préfère le film
[Applaudissements]
ici
on nous dit sors
pareil il y a quelque chose en amalgame
qui est très très fréquent là parce que
vous ce que vous venez de décrire c'est
une mise en sécurité oui donc c'est pas
une punition le parent qui craque n'a
pas une une
visée éducative dans le fait d'éloigner
son enfant il va le mettre en sécurité
pour lui ne pas péter un plomb donc ok
c'est pas une punition une violence
éducative ordinaire il y a le terme
éducatif mettre en enfant dans sa
chambre pour qu'il réfléchissent à un
comportement mais ce n'était pas adéquat
n'est pas autonomique de l'autre on peut
à la fois par sécurité pour l'enfant le
dire voilà va dans ta chambre et en même
temps dans un second temps cet enfant
trouvera dans l'espace de sa chambre un
endroit de réflexion un endroit pour se
poser et réfléchir à ce qu'il a fait la
saint malheureusement les recherches ne
le montre pas voilà alors si tu as pas
fait de recherche
d'utiliser l'argument d'autorité mais
mentalement les études en psychologie ne
le montrent pas et ne permettent pas de
prouver que l'enfant a compris le sens
de la punition oui d'accord avec Papa
positive oui vous connaissiez ou pas oui
on fait quelques mois qu'on collabore
ensemble en fait
j'avais eu des enfants la petite
histoire non si ce n'est des outils
qu'on a créé pour accompagner les
parents ça je sais pas si on voit que
les enfants
c'est pas l'ordre du jour à l'instant
voilà pardon si je peux me permettre
pardon
ce que je j'entends c'est que on a été
éduqué d'une certaine façon on a des
outils en main justement par rapport à
cet héritage qu'on a reçu il se peut
qu'on est qu'on est tous été puni autour
de la table on a pu aussi ressentir une
certaine humiliation ou des émotions
plutôt désagréables par rapport à ça et
peut-être que sans cette punition on ne
réagit
à l'identique ou mieux parce qu'en
réalité sous la contrainte par exemple
c'est quand je suis sur l'autoroute et
que je ralentis en voyant le radar
est-ce que je se respecte vraiment la
règle ou pas
parce que j'agis par peur d'être puni
par peur de savoir une amie je n'ai pas
été élevé de la façon je ne reproduis
pas en gros c'est mes parents donc il y
a déjà il y a une vraie rupture amoureux
de production c'est vraiment une
conviction et je le vérifier sur le
terrain avec mes enfants alors qu'est-ce
que vous appelez punir par exemple un
exemple précis une situation précise
effectivement expliquer pourquoi il ne
faut pas faire ça et éloigner l'enfant
de domaine
privé d'un jeu privé d'une sortie privée
de quelque chose qu'il aime bien qui
n'est pas un dur et qui est un privilège
et qu'il faut qu'il comprenne que c'est
un privilège et que ça ça se mérite
aussi c'est un cadeau
alors moi je suis très heureux des
enfants j'aimerais parler en
circonstance de cause puisque j'étais
une enfant de la DASS et j'étais une
enfant battue et à force d'être
réprimandé d'être puni de se prendre des
claques dans la gueule
des injustices des humiliations totales
alors effectivement ça fait de vous une
personne qui est complètement différente
avec des émotions des ambitions qui sont
complètement surdimensionnés mais ça
nous laisse des énormes séquelles mental
et affective donc je demande à tous les
gens qui ne regardent en aucun cas de
lever et de punir les enfants à des
des séquences et des émotions extrêmes
qui nous laissent des traumatismes à vie
dans l'affective et dans la vie
professionnelle ne portez pas la main
sur les enfants et ni sur les chiens je
parle des chiens également parce que
j'aime également les chiens et voilà
donc voilà et je parle vraiment en
circonstance de cause et peut-être que
vous voulez pouvoir me répondre à ma
cycose il y a à ma situation familiale
en ayant vécu cet acharnement physique
alors effectivement ça fait de vous
quelqu'un différent ça c'est sûr tout à
fait et d'ailleurs marine pourra
s'exprimer plus longuement là-dessus
puisqu'elle est spécialisée en
neurosciences et donc les
neuropsychologue
il y a des conséquences effectivement
sur sur la structure du cerveau et
lorsqu'un enfant est exposé à des
violences alors attention je distingue
je parle de violence et je parle de
récurrence de violence je parle de
violence plus ou moins intenses on va on
va garder quand même mesure de tout cela
on voit effectivement des modifications
et ça peut aussi
altérer certaines fonctions comme
l'apprentissage un enfant qui aura été
exposé à des violences il va peut-être
avoir une mémoire beaucoup moins bonne
qu'un autre enfant qui aura été élevé
dans la bienveillance des problèmes de
concentration il peut y avoir aussi
d'autres pathologies qui peuvent se
déclencher tu peux tu peux peut-être
laisser un mot sur ce sujet
on observe aussi une différence
structurelle au niveau du cerveau chez
ses enfants là il une diminution enfin
en tout cas une ce qu'on appelle une
atrophie dans le jargon de 10 à 20% de
certaines structures cérébrales donc ces
enfants là ont des cerveau plus petit
alors ça veut pas dire qu'ils sont moins
intelligents nécessairement ça dépend
aussi de tout le parcours de vie
évidemment mais voilà il part avec un
une difficulté supplémentaire alors
juste tu voulais répondre à Gilles je
crois oui d'habitude j'ai hâte de
t'entendre
on parle pas de violence on parle pas de
maltraitance on parle d'éducation
faut-il punir les enfants je sais pas
comment on fait le métaphy moi je sais
pas comment
tous s'échapper de manière éducative
donc j'ai hâte de t'entendre
la première chose c'est que articule
bien vas-y ferme bien ta gueule
la première chose c'est que moi
je pense que j'ai été éduqué par mes
parents pardon père et que j'étais
effectivement dans la crainte et dans le
respect de mon père et de ma mère et je
voulais que ça change absolument tout
évidemment et comme j'ai été dans la
crainte de mon père et de ma mère qui
mange je pense bien éduqué et bien élevé
alors évidemment je parle pas de cou
hein mais moi j'étais dans la dans la
crainte de ce que allait penser ma mère
de ce qu'elle est pensé mon père donc
dans le respect de mes parents et je
pense que ce qui manque aujourd'hui avec
ses principes à la con dont tu fais
référence c'est que à force de dire aux
enfants fais ce que tu veux tu vas taper
à l'âge de 16 ans oui bonjour monsieur
ici gendarmerie il t'en garde un vue
parce qu'il a piqué sa gueule ou bien il
a monté un truc de digue etc tous les
jours je pense que la vraie le vrai
problème aujourd'hui et ça je suis très
sérieux entre quand on parle de retour à
la au respect à l'autorité etc tout ce
qu'on est en train de faire là on est en
train de détruire totalement totalement
nos enfants parce que c'est absolument
aberrant qu'un enfant soit ne
comprennent pas très tôt et très vite ce
qu'est ce qu'est la vérité le respect de
l'autre voilà et ça je vais vous dire
que c'est principe là autorité respect
et et j'irai adhésion si on ne fait pas
ça à un enfant vous en faites
potentiellement des délinquants des gens
des enfants à problèmes des mauvais
élèves à l'école et moi j'étais je
remercie mes parents de m'avoir aidé
comme ça j'ai voulu faire tout l'inverse
et je peux le dire ça a été échoué ça a
été une fois radotage
[Musique]
j'ai fait l'inverse de ce qui m'a rendu
qui m'a moi qui m'a élevé ce qui m'a
rendu service j'ai pensé l'inverse j'ai
tout donné à mes enfants voilà pas de ce
qui va pas du pognon des cadeaux des
machins les trucs et c'est un désastre
alors ça marche pas là ça ne marche pas
ça ne fonctionne pas alors et d'ailleurs
je vois bien parce que Julien le premier
a été élevé avec un peu plus d'autorités
comme par hasard il s'en sort un peu
mieux Simon il a été élevé alors lui
pauvre il était vraiment banquier entre
les deux et ça va ça va mieux mais
c'était très compliqué Enzo alors Enzo
ça a été le chouchou l'enfant roi je
pense que c'est voilà c'est pour
l'instant c'est pas terrible et
effectivement aujourd'hui avec mon petit
dernier parce que je me suis fait des
enfants
Gabriel et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
Gabriel effectivement aujourd'hui Il a 2
ans et je le mets au piqué alors vous
allez dire que je suis un monstre avec
mais bien sûr avec plaisir
tu décris un débordement émotionnel et
une réaction de stress et de colère
c'est-à-dire que lorsqu'on a recours à
l'aéroport et lorsqu'on a recours à par
exemple ce type d'attaque tais-toi ta
gueule c'est ça veut dire qu'on est dans
une réaction de stress vous parlez de
lui non mais par exemple
en fait c'est comme dit je sais pas mon
enfant dire à notre enfant arrête de
crier maintenant de pouvoir te répondre
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que on
est on n'a pas eu cet apprentissage
émotionnel en tant qu'adulte on est
arrivé à un certain point ou lorsqu'on
ressent une émotion désagréable et qui
déborde et ça ça peut s'expliquer très
facilement au niveau du cerveau
on pète un câble c'est ce que tu disais
tout à l'heure c'est à dire qu'on va
avoir recours à quelque chose qui va
nous soulager peut-être la punition
d'ailleurs soulage la douleur qu'on peut
ressentir par quand par exemple on est
face au comportement d'un enfant qui est
perçu comme une attaque et on va donc
utiliser la punition en guise de
soulagement mais c'est un cercle vicieux
parce que Benjamin c'est pour lui je
vous le dis franchement je vous aime
beaucoup mais vous êtes le prototype du
mauvais père c'est à dire que vous avez
avoué là que vous projetez vous rendez
compte de ce que vous allez faire le
petit dernier je l'ai vu il est
admirable c'est un bébé fantastique vous
allez le gâcher vous allez le gâcher
parce que vous allez projeter sur lui
vos propres névroses
dans le camp du NON vous incarnez le
pire Castaldi vous êtes le pire de ce
qu'il y a là le pire de tour avec
Gabriel je vais user d'autorité pour
qu'il comprenne très vite
pour petit il a rien demandé le petit
Gaby j'ai vu le petit Gaby il a rien
demandé
de la punition hello
mais il est au piquel le petit gabyle
c'est pas bien ce que vous faites
vous avez vu le petit il ne manque de
rien le petit Gaby je l'ai vu c'est chez
vous
moi
[Musique]
honnêtement non maman et papa quand je
fais une bêtise on en discute et puis
après j'ai peut-être été plié une fois
téléphone mais c'est parce que la
médecine était vraiment grave tu peux
nous dire c'était quoi là
est-ce que ça fait vraiment
on a la chance d'avoir il est là est-ce
que ça fait est-ce que ça te fait de la
peine quand le petit Gabriel est puni ce
petit ange je pense que le piquet c'est
c'est quand même du c'est pour rigoler
de quoi ah non je vais m'occuper
vraiment
[Applaudissements]
si je peux te poser une question tu
disais que tu ne te rappelais pas de la
bêtise en question donc est-ce que tu as
compris pourquoi tu ne devais pas agir
comme ça
j'ai compris et je sais pourquoi j'avais
fait ça et j'ai pas recommencé je pense
que tu t'en souviens très bien
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas d'enfants mais effectivement
j'ai éduqué mon chien et ça c'est très
bien passé donc je
on peut s'arrêter là je pense que c'est
possible
effectivement fonctionne chez les
animaux et j'ai sans doute chez les chez
les petits chez les enfants aussi mais
moi ce que je voulais dire c'est que
l'amour est chez les enfants ne suffit
pas il faut mettre un cadre parce que
sinon quand on voit les parents qui
disent ah non mais on le laisse faire
c'est éducation positive et ils font
n'importe quoi donc le nom c'est très
important chez les enfants et le nom le
nom bête et méchant le nom pourquoi tu
peux pas faire ça parce que tu vas faire
du mal parce que ça va pas parce que tu
vas blesser des autres gens et ce qui
est aussi important de dire je pense
c'est que il faut quand même apprendre
la frustration des enfants par exemple
mes parents ne m'ont jamais puni donc
j'ai jamais été frustré et du coup à
l'âge adulte aujourd'hui j'ai beaucoup
de mal à gérer mes frustrations je
supporte pas que d'être frustré ou qu'on
me dise non par exemple et c'est pour ça
que quand on est petit on n'a pas envie
d'avoir une punition mais je pense que à
l'âge adulte après au final on se dit
c'est quand même mieux pour la
répercussion sur les enfants sur la
frustration je pense que ce qui est
important c'est d'apprendre aux enfants
à la gérer la frustration oui ou à la
gérer oui parce que d'abord
avec des copains qui leur arrache un jeu
des mains la frustration ils vont y être
confrontés toute leur vie
quelque chose
la dernière fois la dernière fois j'ai
des extensions c'est bien c'est mon fils
qui a fait une soirée à l'école
la frustration donc les parents n'ont
pas besoin de l'amener sur ça s'il y a
des mecs qui lui envolent les bails tout
ça voilà dans la forme j'ai des je vous
jure que c'est vrai j'ai des élèves qui
sont venus à la maison mon fils avait
fait une soirée en soirée
il a fait une soirée il a 10 ans ça fait
une soirée jusqu'à 1h du matin
et donc moi je suis convoqué tout le
monde à la fin
ce qui avait des cinquièmes tout ça des
4e
ça va ça se passe bien à l'école
[Rires]
éducation positive
[Applaudissements]
avec les voitures
à travers des mots qui font peur menaces
peur maltraitance est-ce que vous avez
pas peur de décrédibiliser des vrais cas
où il y a vraiment des parents qui sont
extrêmement dur qui sont violents en
employant les mots menaces là je l'ai
entendu parler de peur aussi pour tout
et n'importe quoi bah la peur c'est une
émotion de base si on emploie pas
de toutes les émotions d'ailleurs
engueuler son enfant parce qu'il a fait
une connerie c'est normal ça vous
m'entendez jamais le dire
ce que je fais c'est que j'apporte des
solutions j'essaye d'apporter tu as
jamais jugé des choses à tester aussi
des éclairages par exemple quand je
parlais de l'héritage de ce qu'on a pu
avoir en terme de d'éducation il faut en
être conscient que peut-être que
lorsqu'on est en train de crier sur
notre enfance c'est pas nous en fait
c'est notre parent c'est que tu es
enfant qui criait sur nous et à un
moment il faut être capable de dire
alors le cadre concrètement justement
c'est bon c'est un peu la spécialité de
la maison j'ai envie de dire
déjà les interdits ce qu'on disait ce
qu'on disait jusqu'à présent un interdit
on a presque envie d'aller au-delà de
l'intérieur
c'est mieux une règle pour commencer
c'est mieux les limites
déjà des limites qui s'adapte alors
le jeu il a un terrain tout à fait si on
passe la limite c'est plus du jeu petit
exemple on a un jeu de société est-ce
qu'on est capable de jouer avec
uniquement les interdits
la série est triste parce qu'on ne peut
pas faire si on a une liste tout ce
qu'on peut pas faire on a par exemple je
trouve c'était quelconque le monopoly on
a une liste tout ce qu'on peut faire
est-ce qu'on est capable de jouer non
par exemple au foot tu as pas le droit
de jouer en dehors des limites du
terrain de foot on a les règles aussi
je ne si je ne parle que d'interdits
souvent c'est un biais un peu tu peux tu
peux adhérer ça c'est à dire que on a
tendance à tourner les choses de manière
négative par exemple ne crie pas ne
court pas ne marche pas ne marche pas
les enfants alors qu'il faudrait dire
ferme ta gueule
dans sa tête mais t'inquiète pas en vrai
non alors justement le problème avec
l'enfant
de poser plus de questions je pense que
le c'est pas une question de temps parce
que le temps on prend autant de temps à
formuler positivement quelque chose et
je dirais même on perd plus de temps en
forme bien négativement parce qu'il y a
plus de mots ne pas faire plutôt que
faire mais il faut dire à tout le monde
compliqué
merci merci à tous merci ne pas mal
parler à leurs enfants on le voit ça au
supermarché c'est horrible moi je parle
jamais à la maison par contre eux